hey everyone welcome to another HD
tutorial in this video I'm going to try
to show you guys how to customize your
google your gmail themes and settings
etc so they can actually have your own
look when you're using your gmail so i'm
going to use firefox for this particular
episode i'm usually see me using safari
but this is just for this particular
episode so i'm going to go to the
regular Google homepage this is if
you're not using thunderbird by the way
so if you're actually using your web
browser to go into google and check your
gmail this is how you do it so we're
gonna go is to actually the gmail button
it's going to load first of all my gmail
account you can see how many billions of
youtube videos left answer so first of
all go to settings and you're going to
go to the themes tab on the settings
part and you see right off the bat
there's a ton of settings so you can
choose our mountains marin a dusk shiny
different boyish your girlish settings
and then the last one here after
terminal is choose your own colors and
when you click on that window will pop
up where you can actually choose the
color for every single aspect of your
page so if i click on this one I can
pick my background color text I can pick
just the text of the page itself i can
pick every single color about the entire
page this can add fun i want it to be
blue i can just make it red for example
and then i would save that theme and it
would apply it to my actual my actual
gmail now i'm not going to spend time
applying the entire theme so real quick
like to show you the pebbles theme right
here just by clicking on it then it's
already applied it to the entire gmail
thing off i was recording the entire
screen you can see you can see the
background is kind of grayish it as the
pebbles background you can also upload a
file to be that actual background image
if you like so that is just quick way
for you guys to actually customize your
gmail you know the whole theme of it if
you're getting bored with the one you
are already have here's a contrast black
one that's pretty cool if you don't
actually have a theme for firefox then
a cool way to get the look you like
working on your gmail so that's just a
quick little tutorial for you guys who
are still using using Thunderbird that I
am if you still go to your web browser
to check your gmail one year and you're
not using offline gmail and everything
that is a quick way to do it so I hope
you found this tutorial helpful and
thanks for watching if you have any
other ideas for me send me a quick
request and i will quickly get back to
you guys video response as soon as I
cannot do the best I can thanks for
watching guys peace